الحرب في اوكرانيا تاخذ منعطفا جديدا خاصه
مع اعتزام واشنطن ارسال قذائف مدفعيه من
اليورانيوم المنظم
وفق صحيفه وولد لكن ادخال سلاح حساس كهذا
الى ساحه المعركه بقدراته التدميريه
الهائله وتاريخه الطويل من الاضرار بعيده
المدى التي تتجاوز ساحه المعركه يثير
القلق من تداعياته اليورانيوم المنضب له
خواص اليورانيوم الطبيعي نفسها الا انه
يحتوي على 60% من اشعاع اليورانيوم
الطبيعي ويتكون من ثلاثه نظائر من
اليورانيوم هي يورانيوم اثنان ثلاثه اربعه
يورانيوم
2 3 8 وصفت هذه القذائف بانها تضرب الهدف
بقوه قطار
وواشنطن ليست الاولى فمن قبلها تعودت لندن
كييف بتلك القذائف في حزمه واحده من
دبابات شالنجر هذه القذائف تشكل خطرا
محتملا على الصحه اذا تسربت الماده الى
الجسم سواء من خلال الشظايا او عند
الاستنشاق وفق ما ذكره الموقع الالكتروني
لوزاره شؤون المحاربين القدماء الامريكيه
غير ان موقع الامم المتحده يشير الى انه
وفقا لنتائج الدراسات التي شاركت فيها
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه فان
التهديد الاشعاعي للسكان والبيئه الناتجه
عن التلوث المحلي للمنطقه بجزيئات صغيره
من اليورانيوم المنظم بسبب استخدام
الذخيره ليس كبيرا تاريخ استخدام واشنطن
لهذه القذائف يعود الى سبعينات عندما بدا
الجيش الامريكي في انتاج قذائف اليورانيوم
المنضب الخارقه للدلوع
كما اضافته الولايات المتحده الى دروع
الدبابات المركبه وذخيره الهجوم البري
للقوات الجويه ايتن المعروفه باسم قاتل
الدبابات
ورسميا تعتبر ذخائر اليورانيوم المستنفذ
ليست اسلحه نوويه او كيميائيه ولا يحضر
استخدامها او تصنيعها باي شكل من الاشكال
في الاتفاقيات الدوليه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقص
ص على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات